so democrats are trying to blame this
all on the supply chain issues but it's
not just the supply chain issues it's
when you pay people to stay home when
you incentivize people to stay home and
when you treat them for a year and a
half as wards of the state it's very
difficult to get wards of the state to
start being independent human beings
again people become risk-averse people
become afraid
it's sort of like the problem that you
have at places like sea world where you
take a wild animal you put in a
domesticated situation
and then you feed it fish every single
day you can't just release it back in
the wild because it won't know what to
do
this is what we've done with huge swaths
of the american population we've made
them dependent on the federal government
to the point that people don't know how
to undergo risk anymore we may have
reached the end of risk the end of risk
sounds really nice except that real
world risk still exists you're just
shielded from it you're shielded from it
by the decline of the united states
if the united states absorbs all the
risk then in the end there won't be any
innovation and there won't be any growth
dhl executive jim monkmeyer was on
national tv over the weekend he says
these supply chain issues are going to
continue all the way through 2022. if
there's a truck available to get cargo
off the docks of the port it could come
to a warehouse like this how long the
goods wait for the next truck is another
potential delay i think domestically
because the truck driving shortage is
such an issue we're going to see issues
all the way through 2022. okay meanwhile
people to judge and this really does sum
up the entire problem so pete booty
judge is the supposedly brilliant
secretary of transportation we know he's
brilliant because he taught himself
norwegian in order to read a book or
something i mean sure he was kind of a
mediocre mayor of south bend indiana who
couldn't even fill the potholes and then
was made the secretary of transportation
for diversity purposes
but
this this brilliant human being who was
going to fix all of our problems right
he was one of the great administrators
who's going to fix our problems he went
completely awol for two months right
completely awol and nobody bothered to
ask where he was
he was on paid paternity leave
now i'm not going to get into the debate
over whether men should take paternity
leave
i don't have a general problem with men
taking a certain amount of paternity
leave although i think two months is is
too long a time and i'll tell you on a
personal level
you know my thank god we have a family
structure my my in-laws came down my mom
was available when we had all three of
our babies my paternity lasted maybe a
day and a half
like i'd come home early i'd try to
clear my schedule as much as i could to
help out my wife and i will say that i
think the factors are very different for
paternity leave when you're taking care
of a woman who is recovering from an
actual physical trauma which is what
birth is as opposed to when you just
have a surrogate bird the babies like
that the factors are just different
that's not to say that if people judge
isn't contributing at home that's fine
i don't want to pay for it
and not for two months i'm gonna pay for
it for two weeks
i get it
but
for two months it's kind of a long time
in the middle of a supply chain crisis
anyway
people who judge goes absolutely awol
for two weeks and then he comes back
long enough to do state of the union
which is really what our government
officials right now they just they're
for the innovation
and they themselves
are kind of lazy i mean they themselves
don't really do anything
they are administrators who spend every
day writing rules for you and they're
not paying attention to any of the rules
for themselves and then drawing a
government paycheck while keeping their
eye on the prize i mean the reason that
people do judges secretary of
transportation is because he wants to
run for president
he couldn't win a senate slot in india
he couldn't win a gubernatorial slot in
indiana so he ran for president as a
mayor of a small town
and then thanks to his diversity
quotient he was elevated into the
cabinet with no qualifications for this
position other than he likes choo choo
trains
i mean he literally said that he
literally in his opening speech he was
like i love trains trains are great
trains are yeah great i'm glad that you
once read murder on the orient express
dude not sure why that qualifies you to
help run the nation's supply chain
anyway p booty judge as well was
admitting over the weekend that there
are going to be supply chain problems
into next year
well certainly a lot of the challenges
that we've been experiencing this year
will continue into next year but there
are both short-term and long-term steps
that we can take to do something about
it
okay um
so
that's not great the good news is that
booty judge was on national tv defending
having left his job for two months and
nobody noticing as i said last week if
you leave your job for two months and no
one even bothers to ask where you are
that means your job is completely
superfluous and we should eliminate your
entire department
hey i don't even understand how that
works if i went absent from this show
for a day i get emails from people who
are like where's the show
if my producers just took off for two
months at a time they would no longer
work here because that's not a real
possibility you can't do that at the
very least you got to delegate it to
your to your deputy okay but here is
pete buda judge saying paid family so
now he's gonna tell us how hard he is
working
as a father with his
co-father husband taking care of babies
like again not to demean family work
because you know working at home is a
thing and being with your kids is
definitely a lot of work it just came
off a weekend of being with my kids it's
a lot but you're being paid to be
secretary of transportation i don't
think anybody the debate here is not
over whether men should spend more time
with their kids the debate here is
whether the federal government should
pay men to spend more time with their
kids while completely abdicating their
jobs in the middle of an inflationary
shipping crisis here is pete booty judge
defending staying home and feeding the
babies while completely abdicating his
job
paid family leave is important it's
important as a matter of family values
it's important to our economy and one
more thing that i think is uh maybe
under appreciated
when somebody welcomes a new child into
their family and goes on leave to take
care of that child that's not a vacation
it's work it's joyful wonderful
fulfilling work but it is work and it's
time that our nation join pretty much
every other country in the world and
recognize that so i noticed that you're
getting benefits and living off those
benefits people judge that i pay for so
that's exciting stuff by the way most
major american companies do have some
sort of paternity or maternity leave so
it's not like people judge is preaching
to anybody here he's just growing a
third arm to pat himself on the back
right here he just has no good answer as
to why he just took off for two months
so he was asked specifically by jake
tapper so why didn't you just appoint an
acting secretary like you were just gone
so the answer here by the way is the
entire biden administration should go on
paternity leave like all of you just go
away the country would be better off if
you just left because all you're doing
is sitting around and spending all of
our money while patting yourselves on
the back for being lazy bums here's pete
booty judge
why didn't you
or the department of transportation make
an official announcement when you went
on parental
leave and why did you not appoint an
acting secretary while you were away
well so the way this works is there is a
deputy secretary polly trottenberg who's
doing phenomenal work and who as deputy
secretaries do can fill in when a
secretary is not available now look even
though i've been on paternity leave and
i'm proud of it
obviously given the nature of my job
when you take a job like mine you
understand and accept that you're going
to have to be available
24 7 depending on what's going on and
you're going to have to engage and i did
okay he didn't literally no one knew he
was gone for two months no one knew he
was gone
like that was not a thing and then he he
tells the final lie again and this is
the one that really matters which is
that
we can innervate you into complete
compliance right
you shouldn't worry about any of the
economic problems you're seeing you
shouldn't worry about the inflation you
shouldn't worry about the fact nobody's
going back to work it's actually good
all of this is good
right sure china's firing hypersonic
low-orbit missiles to test against the
united states
and sure the united states is in a
complete state of surrender on on the
foreign policy stage and sure we are
facing extraordinary rates of inflation
we are facing people not going back to
work we are facing a completely
innervated american public but this is
all good according to booty judge part
of what's happening isn't just the
supply side it's the demand side demand
is off the charts retail sales are
through the roof and if you think about
those images of
ships for example waiting at anchor on
the west coast you know every one of
those ships
is full of record amounts of goods that
americans are buying because demand is
up because income is up because the
president has successfully guided this
economy out of the teeth of a terrifying
recession okay is that what's going on
right now is that this
commander-in-chief has guided the
economy out of a terrifying recession
because i'm getting the impression that
this commander-in-chief is guiding
america into a recession for no reason
at all considering we put the entire
economy of the united states in an
artificial coma for a year
we're in a battle for the culture and
for our values like and subscribe to
help keep our videos on the front line
of the fight and top of your feed